it's because
you're you're watching me
but you're in too much of a rush
you're going so we're going to do the
footwork now
i'm going to step right over there
now i want to relax the shoulder but i
mustn't try and bring him with me
because he won't want to come
so i can't take his mind so he's got me
i want to say to him i need you to keep
thinking that you've got me so i'm
dissolving from matthew
i'm dissolving i'm bending my knees from
matthew now i need to get under that
elbow so when i do that
before there's a block if i go in that
you can feel it
so i've not got to go in i've got to
turn that
and now i'm going to go in but i'm not
going to go in i'm going to go round
i'm going to sort of go around here i'm
showing you silly footwork but
i need matthew to be happy that he's got
me
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
actually just going to shift
nothing here i'm shifting my center
you know you can always add
that's that that's that's up to you you
know when we're
feeling great and we're training yeah
blast away
but to find this answer
i do it this way
but if you want to fill the benefits
since you used to say
you've got to feel
good in jigatai
and then you come in
you go here you bring this and you come
up his body
and you turn your hips
and then the only reason you put your
arms out you don't need no power here
the only way because your hips to do it
the only time you're going to need to
put your hands there is in case this leg
takes a flyer and takes your teeth out
so
yeah so when you end up like that it's
when he kicks your legs that's why you
look the other way
so you're all wanting to go further
than what you should be you you need to
be
you need to be
learning how soft you can
do it oh i can feel a block i mustn't go
in yet then so what am i going to do
but i want to go in
let's try changing my foot
well that's a bit easier
you've got to change
what you think because you're the most
intelligent person you know
you know as far as
making a decision
we've got a flat that's just flooded can
you quickly send some people i'll get
back to you in a month or two how long
will his business last
so
we make decisions every day we've got to
now make them in seconds milliseconds
i've done everything i'm showed you
but in
see you still come to one yeah you're
doubting it though aren't you
slightly see so i'm picking up
we'll say
mind to mind things
my arm isn't in the correct position
where i would want to be
but i said i don't need my arm because
i'm doing my hips
so when i say come and go blocking
blocking it's all because you're all
there
i can see that bit
you should not be there but
down here
i've talked enough